Générique
...
- Kathia Gilder: Bonjour à toutes
et à tous.
Bienvenue dans "Parlement hebdo".
26 minutes pour revoir les temps
forts de l'actualité parlementaire
avec un invité.
- Alexandre Poussart: Aujourd'hui,
nous accueillons Yannick Jadot.
Vous avez été candidat à la
présidentielle.
Vous avez été élu sénateur.
- Kathia Gilder: On va revenir sur
le nouveau visage du Sénat.
La majorité de droite sénatoriale
a été confortée.
La gauche progresse.
Elisabeth Borne a déclenché
l'article 49.3 de la Constitution,
le 12e de la législature, pour
faire passer le projet de loi de
programmation des finances
publiques.
Il avait été rejeté l'an dernier.
Y aura-t-il une taxe
super-profits?
Pas si vite, mais l'idée est
remise sur la table à l'occasion
de l'examen du budget.
- Alexandre Poussart: Le Sénat a
été renouvelé de moitié, dans une
certaine stabilité.
Plusieurs présidents de groupes
politiques ont été réélus.
- Le Sénat, version septembre
2023.
De la stabilité et de la
nouveauté.
La droite conserve sa majorité,
mais perd quelques sièges.
Pour le reste, on prend les mêmes
et on recommence.
- Pour moi, c'est un honneur
d'être réélu.
Pour le Sénat, c'est fondamental.
Imaginez que le groupe fondamental
soit désuni.
Le Sénat s'effondrerait.
- Présidence de groupe conservée
pour Hervé Marseille, mais le
problème est ailleurs, pour le
sénateur qui espérait voir de
nouveaux membres.
- On va en gagner, mais combien,
ça fait partie des mystères.
- Vous en avez combien, à l'heure
actuelle?
- On avait 57 membres.
On est à 56-57.
- Hervé Marseille doit faire face
à François Patriat et Claude
Malhuret pour le groupe des
Indépendants.
Pour le Parti Socialiste, Patrick
Kanner était opposé à Eric Rouche,
candidat soutenu par Olivier
Faure.
- Le score est très net en ma
faveur.
Mon message était de dire que
chacun présentait un programme et
qu'on pouvait regarder ce qui
était compatible.
Nous voulons un groupe socialiste
rassemblé.
- Côté écologiste, la présidence
du groupe est conservée.
Mathilde Olivier est un des
nouveaux visages du Sénat.
Autre nouveauté: le retour du RN
avec trois sénateurs qui entrent
au palais du Luxembourg.
Gérard Larcher devrait rester
maître du Sénat.
- Alexandre Poussart: Pourquoi
avoir choisi le Sénat?
- Yannick Jadot: Parce que notre
pays ne va pas bien.
Notre pays est tétanisé.
Il fait du surplace.
Il n'arrive plus à se projeter
dans un avenir qu'il juge
angoissant, avec un présent
inquiétant.
On voit toutes les pensées
politiques rétrogrades,
conservatrices, y compris
d'extrême droite, mythifier un
passé.
J'ai participé au Sénat.
Je veux remettre notre pays en
mouvement.
Je veux que l'agenda écologique ne
soit pas un agenda où on fait
semblant.
Il y a de plus en plus
d'injustices sociales et un
affaissement démocratique, ce qui
va nous conduire à l'élection de
Marine Le Pen avec un Premier
ministre LR.
Je ne me résigne pas à ça.
- Kathia Gilder: Quels combats
concrets voulez-vous porter au
Sénat?
- Yannick Jadot: Déjà,
l'environnement est une compétence
européenne.
Tout notre droit de
l'environnement, en France, est
construit en Europe.
On voit à quel point...
Il n'est pas toujours
satisfaisant.
La France est mise en demeure pour
non-application du droit européen
sur la pollution de l'air, sur le
climat, sur les espèces protégées,
sur la protection de nos eaux.
Je veux que la France soit à la
hauteur du défi environnemental.
Il y a une épuration ethnique dans
le Haut-Karabakh.
On voit que l'Azerbaïdjan,
aujourd'hui, est laissée libre de
ce que les Nations Unies
considèrent la mise en place d'un
génocide.
- Kathia Gilder: Que fait l'Union
Européenne dans cette situation?
- Yannick Jadot: Pas assez.
La France n'en fait pas assez non
plus.
Pourtant, la France,
historiquement, a été aux côtés
des Arméniens.
Mais là, le fait que l'Azerbaïdjan
produise et nous exporte en Europe
du gaz fait que nous laissons ce
pays sans sanction.
Il va falloir que le Sénat, comme
les autres institutions françaises
et européennes s'en emparent.
Il faut un régime de sanctions
lourdes contre l'Azerbaïdjan.
Il faut qu'on arrête de considérer
que les Arméniens sont le prix à
payer de notre addiction au gaz.
Il y a quelques jours,
le président de Total,
Patrick Pouyanné,
était avec le président Aliyev
alors que s'organisait
le génocide des Arméniens.
- Alexandre Poussart: Revenons sur
votre arrivée au Sénat.
- Yannick Jadot: Les élections
sénatoriales, c'est fait pour
élire des sénatrices et des
sénateurs.
C'est compliqué.
Les Français passent à côté de ce
scrutin.
C'est normal.
Ce sont des grands électeurs, des
élus dans les collectivités
locales, mais il n'y a pas de
secret.
Le scrutin sénatorial est fait
pour élire des sénateurs et des
sénatrices.
Je suis très content d'arriver au
Sénat.
Cette maison a pris encore plus de
place dans notre démocratie sous
la présidence d'Emmanuel Macron.
Ce jeudi, c'était la Journée
internationale pour le droit à
l'environnement, un enjeu
essentiel.
Les écologistes ont porté la
constitutionnalisation du droit à
l'IVG, par exemple.
C'est une institution qui mérite
notre attention.
- Kathia Gilder: Il y a beaucoup
de stabilité dans cette
institution.
Lundi, l'élection du président du
Sénat a lieu.
Gérard Larcher sera sûrement
réélu.
Il n'est pas de votre bord
politique, mais est-ce que vous
lui reconnaissez des qualités?
- Yannick Jadot: Moi, j'arrive au
Sénat.
Je ne vais pas tirer un bilan de
la présidence de Gérard Larcher.
Incontestablement, il a acquis le
respect de tous les groupes
politiques, malgré les divergences
politiques et les différences.
On le verra aussi sur le projet de
loi sur l'immigration.
Mais il est respecté par les
groupes politiques, parce qu'il
les respecte.
- Alexandre Poussart: Parlons de
la gauche sénatoriale, qui sort
renforcée de ces élections.
Le seuil pourrait atteindre les
100 sénateurs.
Quelle doit être la ligne
politique de cette gauche
sénatoriale?
Est-ce que ce doit être la même
que la NUPES?
- Yannick Jadot: Non.
Le Sénat ne fonctionne pas comme
l'Assemblée nationale.
Le Sénat est une institution qui
est assez conservatrice, mais
c'est une assemblée qui fonctionne
aussi sur le compromis.
C'est un peu à distance de
l'agitation médiatique.
Le Sénat est moins porté sur le
buzz, sur l'invective et plus sur
le travail de fond.
Ca ne remet pas en cause le
travail de mes collègues à
l'Assemblée.
Ils ont encore fait des choses
concrètes sur la planification
écologique, sur le budget qui
arrive, mais la perception des
Français de l'Assemblée nationale,
c'est que c'est parfois le bazar.
Ce n'est pas la perception qu'ils
ont du Sénat.
Cela ne veut pas dire qu'il n'y a
pas de tension ou de controverse,
mais c'est moins sujet à la
polémique.
Et puis, ce ne sont pas les mêmes
forces politiques qui sont au
Sénat.
Cela raconte aussi les ancrages
locaux des différentes forces
politiques.
Je suis très content que le groupe
écologiste se renforce au Sénat.
On verra combien nous serons
lundi.
C'est lundi que l'on va formaliser
les groupes politiques.
Mais regardez à Paris.
On est passés à deux sénatrices et
un sénateur.
- Kathia Gilder: Il y a un premier
texte qui arrive au Sénat, c'est
la loi immigration que prépare en
ce moment Gérald Darmanin.
On donnerait des papiers à des
personnes qui travaillent dans des
métiers en tension.
Qu'en pensez-vous?
- Yannick Jadot: Vous voyez bien
que nous sommes dans une
difficulté.
On est aujourd'hui sur un débat
sur l'immigration absolument
dramatique.
Ca pourrait être le débat: "Est-ce
que la Terre est plate?"
La droite et l'extrême droite ont
des conceptions qui n'ont rien à
voir avec la réalité.
C'est de notre responsabilité
collective...
Si quelqu'un vient ici en vous
disant qu'il a vérifié, que la
Terre est plate, vous allez vous
dire qu'il est cinglé.
Quand on parle d'"appel d'air",
quand on dit que régulariser les
sans-papiers, c'est un "appel
d'air"...
Il n'y a pas une étude française,
européenne ou internationale qui
démontre que régulariser, c'est
faire un appel d'air.
Deuxième contrevérité de l'extrême
droite reprise par le président
lors de sa dernière intervention,
c'est qu'il dit que nous sommes un
pays très généreux.
Il sous-entend que les immigrés
viennent pour notre système social
et que notre système social paie
l'immigration.
Toutes les études montrent que les
immigrés contribuent à nos
finances publiques.
Troisième mensonge du président de
la République...
Il faut remettre le débat dans la
vérité.
Il dit que la France paie sa part,
plus que sa part.
Il dit que nous sommes les
meilleurs du monde.
Il dit que nous payons plus que
notre part sur l'accueil des
réfugiés.
C'est faux!
Même sur les Ukrainiens, nous
faisons moins que nos voisins.
Il faut régulariser les
travailleurs sans-papiers.
S'il y a une régularisation
responsable, nous irons vers cette
mesure.
- Kathia Gilder: On va poursuivre.
Six mois après la réforme des
retraites, Elisabeth Borne a
déclenché un nouveau 49.3 à
l'Assemblée nationale.
- Nous avons besoin de cette loi
de programmation de nos finances
publiques.
Nous ne pouvons pas prendre le
moindre risque.
- Les débats auront duré moins de
trois heures lorsqu'Elisabeth
Borne brandit pour la première
fois de cette session le 49.3.
- J'engage la responsabilité de
mon gouvernement sur l'ensemble du
projet de loi de programmation des
finances publiques.
- Ils sont dans un déni
démocratique.
La réponse est commune et unie: la
NUPES portera une motion de
censure.
- La carte du 49.3 utilisée, faute
de majorité absolue à l'Assemblée,
car les oppositions l'avaient
annoncé: pas question de soutenir
cette loi de programmation des
finances publiques.
- Cette orientation budgétaire est
la pire qui ait jamais été faite
dans notre pays.
On parle de 70 milliards
d'économies sur le dos des
Français et des Françaises.
- On prévient les Français depuis
15 mois.
On dit que toutes les postures de
madame Borne sont une comédie.
Le Rassemblement National avait
d'abord obtenu, puis ça s'était
perdu dans les couloirs de Bercy,
un ajustement pour ne pas taxer
injustement les agriculteurs.
- La majorité fustige
l'indignation des oppositions.
- Même quand on parle de 18
milliards de ressources de la part
de l'Europe, même quand on parle
d'une trajectoire de maîtrise de
nos finances publiques, les
oppositions ne sont pas capables
d'être raisonnables.
- Elisabeth Borne aura eu recours
12 fois à l'article 49.3 depuis
son arrivée à Matignon.
- Kathia Gilder: Yannick Jadot,
Elisabeth Borne a donc utilisé 12
fois le 49.3.
Pourtant, c'est sans surprise.
C'était normal que le gouvernement
utilise le 49.3?
- Yannick Jadot: Ce n'est pas
normal.
On devrait parler à l'Assemblée
des grands enjeux du budget avec
les plus riches.
Il y a un an, l'Assemblée
nationale votait majoritairement
pour que l'on ait un budget à la
hauteur du défi de la rénovation
thermique de nos logements.
On sait que ce sont des millions
de familles françaises qui vont
avoir froid cet hiver.
On a besoin de rénover.
On parlait tout à l'heure de
l'Azerbaïdjan.
On doit s'affranchir de nos
dépendances en énergies fossiles.
On doit aider les Français dans
leur pouvoir d'achat.
C'est une discussion sur un
certain nombre de priorités mises
en avant par le président, mais
qui ne se retrouvent pas dans le
budget.
C'est dommage.
Le 49.3, aujourd'hui, est un
constat du dysfonctionnement de
l'Assemblée nationale.
- Kathia Gilder: Mais il a été mis
dans un texte dont la France dit
qu'il est obligatoire pour avoir
le versement des fonds européens.
C'est vrai?
- Yannick Jadot: C'est une blague.
Aujourd'hui, vous savez
parfaitement...
Tout le monde s'est affranchi des
règles budgétaires, qui ne font
plus sens, d'ailleurs.
Le débat européen aujourd'hui, sur
ce qu'on appelle "les critères de
Maastricht", donc à la fois les
déficits de budget et le montant
de la dette, ce débat est à
l'agenda des institutions
européennes pour transformer ces
critères.
La question n'est pas de laisser
filer la dette.
Le ministre Le Maire, a, en
rigolant, reconnu que l'on avait
cramé 12 milliards de protection
sur l'énergie pour les plus riches
dans notre pays et qu'on aurait pu
s'affranchir de cette dépense.
Bien sûr qu'il faut mieux dépenser
l'argent.
Il faut conditionner les aides aux
entreprises et les exonérations
sur les cotisations sociales.
Il faut investir, aujourd'hui, sur
la question climatique.
Ce n'est pas une dette.
C'est un investissement qui nous
permettra de mieux vivre.
L'instrumentalisation de l'Europe
aujourd'hui, elle est totalement
mal placée de la part de ce
gouvernement.
- Alexandre Poussart: Dans le
budget 2024 présenté par le
gouvernement et débattu par les
parlementaires à l'automne, il y a
16 milliards d'euros d'économies,
mais aussi des dépenses qui
augmentent sur certains postes,
notamment la transition
écologique, avec 7 milliards de
dépenses supplémentaires pour
financer le bonus à l'achat de
véhicules électriques.
Il y a aussi le nouveau crédit
d'impôt industrie verte.
Le gouvernement parle de "budget
vert".
Vous êtes d'accord?
- Yannick Jadot: Non.
Ce que j'attendais, ce n'était
pas...
Le président nous a expliqué que,
malgré l'urgence climatique, on
entrait seulement dans un cycle de
chaos climatique.
Ce que l'on voit aujourd'hui est
de plus en plus...
- Kathia Gilder: Et le chèque
carburant de 100 euros?
- Yannick Jadot: Ce n'est pas
suffisant.
Il dit qu'il y aura des avions
verts en 2050.
Il dit qu'on va faire des SUV
électriques.
Mais qui peut se payer un SUV
électrique, aujourd'hui?
On a laissé les alternatives aux
voitures en déshérence: on aurait
dû renforcer le forfait mobilité
dans les entreprises, favoriser le
covoiturage et la mobilité douce.
On n'a pas investi dans le fait de
faire des véhicules électriques
accessibles.
On laisse les constructeurs faire
des voitures à 60.000 euros et
c'est l'argent public qui doit
aider?
Le chèque énergie n'est pas
suffisant.
Il faut aider les plus
vulnérables.
Les vainqueurs de la transition
écologique, ce doit être les plus
vulnérables.
Ce n'est pas un budget vert.
On a un président qui joue avec le
dérèglement climatique.
Il fait semblant.
Il a souvent déclaré la guerre.
Il aurait dû déclarer la guerre au
dérèglement climatique.
Mais il continue à passer des
armistices avec les grands ennemis
qui nous contraignent dans ce
modèle déclinant.
- Alexandre Poussart: La taxe des
super-profits va être remise sur
la table.
- J'entends une petite musique:
plutôt que de demander poliment au
patron de Total ou à des
distributeurs: "S'il vous plaît, à
votre bon coeur, si on peut faire
un geste..."
L'Etat devrait réguler.
Il faut taxer les profits insensés
et exceptionnels que font
certaines entreprises pour que
l'Etat redistribue.
- Vous redemandez cette taxe sur
les super-profits?
- Oui.
- Alexandre Poussart: Est-ce que
vous pourriez vous entendre avec
l'Union Centriste pour voter cette
taxe sur les super-profits?
- Yannick Jadot: Bien sûr, mais le
gouvernement s'oppose à cette
taxe.
Quand je dis que le président
passe son temps à servir les
lobbys du pétrole, des pesticides,
des bagnoles...
Prenez l'entreprise Total.
20 milliards de profits, les trois
quarts redistribués aux
actionnaires, et on se satisfait
que Total dépense quelques
dizaines de millions pour
stabiliser la hausse du prix de
l'essence en faisant une grosse
opération commerciale?
Ce n'est pas possible que des
entreprises se goinfrent pour les
actionnaires, pour leurs profits,
sur les automobilistes, les
consommateurs, les habitants dans
leur logement...
Cela participe à l'écrasement des
Ukrainiens et des Arméniens.
Et ils ne contribuent même pas à
l'effort national!
Les gens deviennent dingues.
Ils voient les milliards valser
dans certaines entreprises.
Ils se font taper parce qu'ils
sont RSA, chômeurs, travailleurs
seniors, parce qu'ils sont mal
logés et qu'ils n'arrivent plus à
payer.
- Kathia Gilder: Cette taxe, c'est
votre combat.
C'est aussi celui de Hervé
Marseille.
Il peut y avoir un accord entre le
Sénat et l'Assemblée nationale?
- Yannick Jadot: Il faut une
majorité.
Vous ne pouvez pas imposer cela au
gouvernement.
Le gouvernement est contre la
justice sociale.
On ne peut pas dire que la droite
soit très sociale et très engagée
sur l'écologie, mais il y a des
parlementaires qui disent que
c'est totalement aberrant de voir
des groupes sur les transports
maritimes, sur l'énergie, sur
l'agroalimentaire, se gaver,
aujourd'hui, sur les
consommateurs.
Ils ne contribuent pas à mettre un
peu de justice sociale dans ce
pays.
Il faut que ce gouvernement ait la
volonté d'accepter de taxer ceux
qui sont des profiteurs de crises.
- Alexandre Poussart: Vous croyez
encore à la proposition d'un ISF
vert?
D'un impôt sur la fortune
climatique?
- Yannick Jadot: Il faudrait le
remettre sur la table.
Les ultra-riches sont beaucoup
plus pollueurs et émetteurs de gaz
à effet de serre que la moyenne
des Français.
C'est notamment à travers leur
patrimoine, leurs placements
financiers.
Bien sûr, il faut l'ISF, l'impôt
sur la fortune.
Il faut remettre un ISF et avoir
un ISF...
J'avais porté un ISF climatique
avec une taxation supplémentaire
sur les placements sur les
patrimoines, lors de la campagne
présidentielle.
Ce serait un impôt exceptionnel
sur les ultra-riches.
- Kathia Gilder: Ce sera le mot de
la fin.
- Alexandre Poussart: Merci
d'avoir été notre invité.
- Kathia Gilder: On se retrouve la
semaine prochaine.
SOUS-TITRAGE: RED BEE MEDIA